hummingbirds are one of the most agile
fliers in the animal kingdom they can
fly in any direction and regularly
perform aerial acrobatics to evade
predators and maintain their demanding
diets maneuverability the ability to
change either speed or direction on the
fly is a hallmark of powered flight and
animals researchers are now trying to
figure out how maneuverability this
interplay between feathers and muscles
weight and air evolved in birds with the
aid of hundreds of hummingbirds the
hummingbird family consists of 337
different species with a variety of body
masses and wing shapes to understand how
these variations affect flight
researchers observed the flight
manoeuvres of 200 hummingbirds from 25
species each bird was placed in a test
chamber for 30 minutes while their
flight was tracked by computer the
computer recorded the bird's flight at
200 frames per second the tracking data
was then analyzed using custom software
the analysis showed that different
species favored some maneuvers over
others and were usually much better at
their preferred maneuvers larger species
tended to have higher maneuverability in
part due to their larger wing size and
muscle capacity not just in relation to
smaller species but in relation to their
bodies as a whole however within these
species heavier hummingbirds tended to
have lower maneuverability researchers
also found that a larger wing area
relative to body mass enhances a humming
bird species acceleration and turning
performance so far these experiments
have only been conducted on hummingbirds
but in the future researchers hope to
branch out to other species also on the
to-do list is the development of small
data loggers that can be attached to
birds in the wild giving researchers
insight on how birds use these flight
maneuvers in their day-to-day lives
[Music]